a statue that was uh involved a bronze
bust of george floyd was defaced on
sunday morning in new york someone threw
some paint at the
at the idol to george floyd the i the
great bronze icon of saint george george
of uh the blessed fake 20 bills or
whatever
so
what is this about why are we defacing
monuments of
george why is there a monument of george
floyd i have no idea why are we defacing
monuments of george floyd
and
why are we defacing monuments of
christopher columbus who's a good man
why are we defacing monuments of george
washington good man of abraham lincoln
good why because we're disagreeing over
what our national symbols are
right that's where a lot of this
division comes from we can't agree the
left wants our symbol to be this guy who
was killed under sad circumstances but
who was also a career criminal who
robbed a pregnant woman at gunpoint who
did a ton of drugs who was committing a
crime well and resisting arrest while he
was killed and so that's sad it's sad
when any man is killed but
very different than uh you know an
innocent martyr and
[Music]
the right wants our statues to be george
washington christopher columbus thomas
jefferson these great men who built our
civilization
which is it we
we will not resolve this rancor in this
division until we can agree on the
shared symbols because the symbols
represent what the country is and right
now we have no idea who we are which is
why people are trying to grab power as
tightly as they can whether they're in
the government they're in big tech
they're in industry to clamp down and
make that decision that decision is
being made right now and we
we need to fight as hard as we can to
keep the country that we want i'm so
glad you like that clip stop what you're
doing
ring the bell subscribe that way you'll
get notifications for the whole episode
of this podcast
also if you want to avoid the
big tech censorship that has been pretty
crazy lately head on over to apple
podcast spotify stitch or google play
wherever you get your podcasts subscribe
to the michael knowles show that is
t-h-e-m-i-c-h-a-e-l-w-l-e-s s
click subscribe leave a five-star review
appreciate it see you next time
[Music]
[Music]